I came into this video playing truth
through mortal mortal maybe the feed on
something else true move from Israel oh
I've got zero olive two against the sky
that's not very much mainline podido
let's see what he is coming up with yeah
I do this with the a6 and so on yeah d 5
mm mm is the capture I cannot die I can
never really remember if i take on d5
here or play Bishop e7 or whatever okay
interesting okay let's just take it and
then is go he goes see for what exactly
and okay well I I should go here anyway
this looks a lot like a Sicilian quite
quite clearly hmm yeah I have this have
the the lousy bishop on one in seven
do I get this treated somehow one and a
memory too much maybe I can just get in
enough counter play on the sea far with
Roxy aid and and so on ya understand
that from the structural point of view
this does not look good but maybe em
it's not that that much of a problem
night c5 in this position is probably
not great but maybe maybe if he takes I
take with the beep on and with a for
being played that's not so clear if this
is a good idea and now i have night to
e6 as well which might support the
trades on g5
okay he wants to wants to go H form
if I get commenced rated I can I can
play with g6 f-fire this position is not
so bad I mean I know it looks bad with
the pawn on d6 and everything but it is
not that clear I can absolutely assure
you g6 and their five h6 was maybe
hanging I guess I better cover that
yeah that's it this is the counter play
why does not having total control in
this position I get some some central
influence going a five wow so
95 I do what he do he plays 95 I guess
okay I seem and if it takes what exactly
is what exactly is he playing then you
cannot go to d to where I mean you can
but 97 traps the rook
that's a no squares
okay so I want an exchange but I still
have the structural issue the King on is
6am at this this will be helpful I guess
k keep it and protect it for the moment
yeah I am I mean he's lost in exchange
but what what he has left is good okay
so rook e8 or something to activate
yeah of course I need you i need to
activate stuff
add this regrouping of the night 35 man
i am not sure if i could have prevented
it but something that it's a very
annoying maneuver white has excellent
compensation here really excellent not
sure about that
I get traits in this is good for me c5
maybe take now Group B a doesn't i get b
3 right okay i guess it didn't make most
of his chance to see an absolutely not
yet around here it looked like why it
has an excellent compensation for the
exchange I don't think I'm I'm not sure
I'm not sure yeah computers unimpressed
just gives black almost a pawn up but I
don't really know look sir it looks
difficult to me all his pieces are well
placed yeah my counselor wants to go
where for here for Luke a5 something
something like this yeah and gives black
a poem but I mean I have to have a white
white it really is so active that that's
compensation and hard to believe that I
should just be be better here I don't
know um yeah I was winning the exchange
but I guess maybe right after that I
made mistakes because he got in too much
activity maybe rue Kade first I'm not
sure I I really didn't anticipate the
night regrouping only here and now it's
really too late i cannot do much I guess
instead of this move I should think
about this because he cannot take really
he cannot take any way because of bein
and this is intending okay five that
looks a bit better yeah difficult yeah
this is a very tricky position on
and it's it's not so easy to appreciate
that the white advantage is not that
great it it looks excellent but I have
some ideas this Quincy six I think there
are some things that that I can suggest
for white for example I think it's not
such a great idea to trade queens maybe
queen bee three years is interesting
just keep the Queen's on because with
Queens on the board this f5 idea is not
not possible not sure I mean I'm not
saying that this is a huge mistake or
anything but I'm not sure if it's such a
great idea I really have okay i
blundered h6 you can just take it a bit
it from from from a general of strategic
point of view I have some ideas here now
playing against this is somewhat
vulnerable porn it's not totally clear
why should be better but it's not not
easy maybe also i mean okay i blundered
this TM i'm not sure about this really
isn't this isn't this something for the
black yeah i mean playable playable I
mean what he did is just giving up
material that I mean maybe yes to take
but that's not a bad center here it's
not it's not so bad not so bad yeah
difficult to play thanks for watching